[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
it's sedition
[Music]
got it
guilty
of a conspiracy of sedition to obstruct
an official proceeding
uh oh uh oh this cannot be good for the
former guy
the Cheeto dusk q and honor this cannot
be good for him
at all
really bad news the other
horrible news for the Cheeto dust cue in
honor
the head Nazi
is Stephen Miller Another Nazi decided
that he would uh
partake in a subpoena with the January 6
grand jury the first witness since
Jack Smith
has taken over as special counsel these
are all significant things
it's all significant that's why he
freaks out over on true social or fraud
social whatever the hell it is
freaking the [ __ ] out and the reason why
is because the walls are closing in
the January 6 select committee has
deposed more witnesses including
kellyanne Conway which I'm not even
really you know I'm not even really sure
what the [ __ ] that's about
like what could she possibly [ __ ]
know other than hearsay
about the state elector scheme
that's I think that's where this is
boiling down to
in in Trump's
criminal liability here is the state
elector scheme because also we have news
that Mark Meadows has been ordered
to go be deposed by the grand jury in
Fulton County
Georgia
this all seems to be part of this scheme
where they were trying to overthrow our
government
foreign
do you think Jack Smith is gonna
overturn rocks that Genie Thomas is
hiding under
what do you think I think he is
I think Jack Smith's investigation here
into the January 6 plot to overthrow our
government
sedition
as it was confirmed by a jury yesterday
sedition
conspiracy of sedition
what was it that they said after January
6 you're like oh you can't call it
sedition
it's not a violent attempt of overthrow
it's not a coup
hmm
can't say that [ __ ] anymore
guilty
of course Stuart Rhodes dodged one
charge but the charge of sedition and
obstruction of official proceeding are
charges he didn't dodge I'm not really
sure exactly
what his um sentencing guidelines are
going to look like but I'm sure it's not
gonna be good
it's not going to be good
it's not going to be good
I would imagine that Stuart Rhodes
probably receives at least 10 to 14
years in a federal prison and he will
serve the majority of those 10 to 14
years
he will get good time
because Stewart seems to always get a
pass in his life
this time he did not
from this jury get a pass
we've had Tasha Adams and Dakota Von
Adams his estranged wife and a strange
son on the show here and we've done an
interview with him she actually Tasha is
a strange wife talks about the actual
story
of how that bonehead lost his eye
he shot it out he shot out his own
[ __ ] eye
it's it's on our YouTube channel go look
at it you just go to the playlist Tab
and go down to Oath Keepers proud boys
that list click on that there's several
interviews with Dakota
on there but there's also interviews
with the interview with Tasha as well so
just go to YouTube and subscribe and you
can find the again that playlist under
the playlist Tab and you can see our
interviews with them
Stewart Rhodes
is Donald Trump here's what I mean by
that they are one in the same type
[ __ ] now they were born
with different spoons in their mouth
Donald Trump was born with the silver
spoon
he's not self-made at all not even a
little bit he's a [ __ ] bonehead
really honestly
he's probably more bone-headed than Elon
Musk he's destroyed more businesses than
him for sure
it's all Bluster it's all [ __ ] it's
all fraud always has been always will be
I mean Jesus Christ is [ __ ] his the
big organization that he claims is the
greatest business of all time and all
this nonsense it's in receiver's
receivership in the state of New York
it's also under criminal investigation
or criminal trial under criminal trial
probably going to receive federal
referrals for tax fraud
to the southern district of New York
he had a failed presidency the only
thing that Donald Trump was able to
accomplish is the president United
States is to make sure Rich
[ __ ] in this country kept their
tax cuts
and got more of a tax cut
while the middle class and lower class
they got a little bit of a tax cut for a
couple years and now they're ripping it
away
foreign
takes hold
as prices are getting higher
the Republicans made sure
that the middle and lower class would
have to pay more
in tax specially income tax because to
have baby that's the [ __ ] tax
that the working class pays
they made sure of that
and are they going to do anything in
this new Congress [ __ ] no they're not
they're not going to do anything at all
in the House of Representatives besides
talk about some [ __ ] guy's laptop
that doesn't exist
foreign
try to impeach Joe Biden that's what
that's the entirety of their [ __ ]
platform and shut down the government
good good luck
that's what they're gonna do
I'm gonna do anything
why would they why would Trump do
anything when he was president Jesus
Christ every week was infrastructure
week every every two weeks he was going
to come out with a health care plan you
remember this greatest health care plan
ever just wait two [ __ ] weeks two
[ __ ] weeks we'll have that some [ __ ]
foreign
do you know who actually passed
infrastructure
Democrats
Democrats did that [ __ ]
do you know actually advanced
Health Care to make sure that people
weren't [ __ ] getting just hosed
Democrats
the inflation reduction act reduced
a whole slew
of prescription drugs
make sure that the government can
negotiate price
Medicare Medicaid
Joe made sure that veterans who have
served our country
received the health care that they
earned and deserved Democrats did that
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did Trump do not a goddamn
thing besides [ __ ] you on your taxes
that's right [ __ ] you on your taxes he
gave the top five percent their break
and everyone else gets to [ __ ] gets
takes it in the ass without the Vaseline
that's out that's how that's what they
do
he's never accomplished anything in his
entire [ __ ] life he bankrupt casinos
casinos are [ __ ] rigged folks it's
it's a rigged game
that's that's the entire point
is it's [ __ ] rigged
everyone knows it even the people
addicted to it are [ __ ] know it's
rigged against them
it's the idea of winning against a
rigged system
that is the attraction Maybe
but he couldn't even keep those
[ __ ] open
Trump Stakes Trump wine Trump whatever
this Trump whatever that Trump
University Trump whorehouse Trump you
Trump Charities can't keep them open
what in the [ __ ] makes anyone think he
lost by three million votes right he
wins on a technicality in 2016. loses by
three [ __ ] million votes
gets his ass stomped in his midterm
eight million more people told him to
[ __ ] off
in 2020.
he backs all kinds of candidates in this
midterm
and they barely
barely win the house
and managed to give away a seat in the
Senate
he's a [ __ ] loser
his entire life is losing
now why is he still walking around
because he's a fraud and he was born
with the Silver Spoon the reason why
Stuart Rhodes is going to [ __ ]
Federal Prison
I don't know when the sentencing is I'm
sure it will be scheduled for some time
probably February of next year maybe
March
depending on how busy that court is
the reason why Stuart Rhodes is going to
federal prison
for sedition
is because he participated in this
Edition
and he doesn't quite have the silver
spoon in his mouth
but Stuart Rhodes and Donald Trump are
one in the same be sure of it
be sure of it
just go watch that interview with Tasha
Adams he's a strange wife she'll tell
you yeah he went to [ __ ] Yale and he
was a [ __ ] attorney but he is he is a
he's just worthless
he's worthless
he thinks he's smart not smart
he's definitely not as smart as he
thinks he is this sounds familiar
doesn't it
I'm telling you
brothers from a different mother
is what Stewart Rhodes and Donald Trump
are
and frankly it's surprising that Donald
Trump has never shot his [ __ ] own eye
out
but I believe that their Fates will be
the same
everything is pointing to this
State elector scheme John Eastman
Jeffrey Clark
Mike Pence
declaring all these these electors
aren't real so we have to have our own
the grand jury in
Georgia
I actually believe that the documents
case
is part of the state elector scheme
that's right I believe
I I don't have any evidence other than I
know who the [ __ ] Donald Trump is
and we've watched him
say his crimes out loud for years now
I believe
that the reason why Jack Smith has has
jurisdiction of the special counsel over
the documents case and the January 6th
case is because they are the same case
they are not a different case
now there may be different crimes
different motivations for part of these
documents but you can be damn sure
that one of the reasons one of the
motivations
that the Cheeto dust cue an honor
stole those documents is to hide this
Edition that Stewart Rhodes and The Oath
Keepers are going to go to prison for
they were just convicted on yesterday
the proud boys trial is coming up too
foreign I believe that those documents
that he stole part of them prove
the sedition
that's why he took them
the other part of the documents
probably show the intelligence
of the Russia collusion No Doubt
and then he stole other ones to sell
them or trade them for something
or maybe hold them over someone's head
as blackmail
this is Trump he didn't take them
because he wanted to hang him on the
wall
because he thinks it's neat to keep him
in his desk drawer I mean maybe a few of
them right to brag you know he's like
this bragging [ __ ] he likes that type
[ __ ] oh look what I got I got a document
no one else can have and no one else can
see but I'll show it to you because I'm
a dumb [ __ ]
but that's why he took the [ __ ]
that's why
it only makes sense right that's why
Jack Smith has jurisdiction over
documents and January 6.
why else why else would the Attorney
General give him jurisdiction over both
those things of both those cases weren't
connected
I mean we have White House logs missing
we know that from the January 6 select
committees open investigation
by telling the American public that hey
there's a bunch of [ __ ] White House
logs that are missing we don't know
where the [ __ ] they're at hmm I wonder
where they're at wonder where they could
be
in a casket somewhere maybe who knows
who knows
but the significance
of Stuart Rhodes and The Oath Keepers
being found guilty and opened Court by a
jury of their peers
of sedition
is very very good for democracy
and it makes it very very bad for the
America First Nazi party
horrible
horrible situation for the American
verse Nazi party
we have good news though
there is good news in this country
and of course
the only good news that we have in this
country I mean besides you know these
[ __ ] Nazis being
found guilty of sedition
is that our government the one we select
the one we elect
that we elected in 2020
did their job yesterday yesterday they
the Senate passed six with 61 votes
topping the 60 threshold I believe Cory
Booker was the 60th vote
in that roll call
topped to 61 votes for the respect of
Marriage Act
what a fantastic day in America
what a fantastic day for Liberty now
I believe that we shouldn't have to have
the Senate declare these things
it should just be a societal Norm but we
can't trust societal Norms anymore
when you're all hopped up on Q Anon when
you're all hopped up on misinformation
and lies
and you have an amplification system of
those misinformation and lies in this
country and you're demonizing demonizing
you [ __ ] are demonizing people
in the lgbtq community yes are there
miscreants in every Community absolutely
I don't think anyone would disagree with
that
but to frame up to frame up that every
single person and even allies of those
people's Liberty
are somehow somehow
they're demons
this is 2022 folks this is 2022.
we don't have to [ __ ] play that
nonsense
and yesterday the Senate passed
the respect for Marriage Act which is
another step forward to making sure that
folks know in this country which party
and who is for
Liberty of all people and two of the
[ __ ] scumbags have voted against this
that stand out to me as Rick Scott and
Marco Rubio of Florida it's not
surprising and Rick Scott and Marco
Rubio the senators from Florida have to
be [ __ ] bigots
I mean they don't want to catch any
Flack
from their their fear hurt down in
Florida
Ron DeSantis
as they decide who are the leaders of
the America First Nazis
they have to really you know dig in
to the whole fourth Reich thing
down in Florida
just dig in
you can't stand up for people's right to
marry who they want to love [ __ ] you
you can't stand up for for for someone
wants to marry who they love rather
rather they're in an interracial
marriage
or they're in in a in in a gay marriage
I don't want to get gay married and then
you have Madison Gotham this is great
this is great Madison gothorne coming
out of Congress goes on the floor
um and gives a speech about his
masculinity and how he doesn't know what
the [ __ ] masculinity is
it's fantastic I'm not sure why these
[ __ ] idiots are so insecure
about their manhood but I got ideas I've
got ideas why they're insecure about
their manhood listen there are plenty
plenty
of members of the lgbtq community that
would whip the [ __ ] out of some straight
white dude I mean absolutely go 10
rounds and smash their [ __ ] face in
you people think just because there's a
certain thing it means a certain thing
it does not
and frankly when you're projecting your
insecurities about your manhood
because people don't wear the clothes
you want them to wear listen to the
music you want them to listen to you
people are [ __ ] boneheads and you're
barking up wrong trees you're totally
underestimating the American people
and that's why Jin Z is gonna bury you
for good
and good for them
and good for the Senate to pass this
bill
to show to show the Next Generation that
hey we are willing to stand up for your
Liberty don't let these people [ __ ]
intimidate you
we are willing to stand up for your
Liberty who you want to love who you
want to marry if you want to marry or
not which I'm not the [ __ ] I would
advise most people that marriage may not
be the best idea
marriage is tough It's A Hard
partnership anyone who's been married
knows that
it's a tough partnership
two people
committing to this
legal partnership
especially over a long period of time
but but to refuse someone's right to
have that to have that hard partnership
get the [ __ ] out of here that's not
Liberty
telling someone wow you're black and
you're white you can't get married well
you're you're a dude and you're a dude
you can't get married well a woman and a
woman can't get married what the [ __ ] do
you care
what what on Earth does it have to do
with you who's someone else [ __ ]
loves
what does it have to do with you and if
you have to ask that question what the
[ __ ] does it have to you then we should
not be [ __ ] same people cannot do
that [ __ ]
that's right
they'll be like oh but you wanted you
lived hard wanted people to wear masks
yeah that had everything to do with
everyone else dummy
gay marriage is not contagious
interracial marriage is not contagious
you stupid [ __ ]
they just don't get what Liberty is
they don't get it and that's why it's
such a victory and I wanted to bring it
up in the first 30 minutes I wanted to
talk about this Edition but I also
wanted to talk about Liberty because you
know that's that's that's part of that's
the entire [ __ ] reason for the show
is the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty get it
[ __ ] through your thick skull
you [ __ ] fascist
you cannot you cannot dictate what
someone else does with their [ __ ]
privacy whether it's the privacy of who
they want to marry and who they want to
love and who they want to [ __ ]
or what they want to dress like
if they want to put on a dress or if
they want to change their gender or be
identified as a different gender what
the [ __ ] does it have to do with you not
a God damn thing just because you're
offended doesn't mean they have to do
anything for you [ __ ]
it is their Liberty to be who they want
to be
and you ain't got no [ __ ] say in it
and if you want to have a say in what
someone else does rather it be their
religion their sex their marriage their
race how they dress how they want to
identify what hair color they want to
have
you're the fascist
and it's only more and more clear when
you support Nazis
this is the type of [ __ ] that Nick
Fuentes
always has been talking about
taking away people's [ __ ] Liberty
because of who they are because he don't
like them
that's why you're aligned with Nazis if
you're standing around going well why
did President Trump meet with Nick
Fuentes who is a holocaust denier he's a
Nazi
yeah he denies the Holocaust but most
Nazis do
it's because you're one of them
if you're wondering why you weren't
horrified
at the news that some [ __ ] weirdo
lunatic
Maga Republican
confused or not went into a place in
Colorado Springs and killed five people
and and
murdered five people assassinated five
people
and injured dozens more
and you're not aware
and you don't get you're not you don't
have the feelings of remorse because
those people are of a certain kind of
folk
that you don't like you're one of them
you're a Nazi
we need to stop we need to stop being
light-footed about this
I wish the media would start talking
like I [ __ ] talk they're not going to
by the way
I mean if you want it real and raw this
is the [ __ ] place to come if you want
to go [ __ ] listen to him [ __ ] act
like we're You Gotta Give
Nazis a couple minutes to talk [ __ ] you
you can go talk to them you can go watch
MSNBC and CNN Fox News whatever you want
to watch you're not going to get that
[ __ ] here
and fake Gabe I'm sure I haven't been
looking at the comments but I'm sure
fake Gabe's like oh you're just calling
people Nazis that's because you are what
do you want me to do what how
I'm not gonna [ __ ] like glove it I'm
not gonna
I'm not gonna be nice to you
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you you don't
want people to be who they want to be
you your Liberty is not affected by them
having the Liberty it's not and because
it's not you don't get to tell those
[ __ ] what they can and can't do
you don't get to dictate someone's
Liberty when it doesn't affect yours
doesn't you don't get to tell them that
that's why the mass thing and the
pandemic thing was different see because
the [ __ ] virus was contagious
someone's marriage is not contagious
someone's religion is not contagious
someone's belief is not contagious
so stop with your [ __ ] nonsense
if you don't like if you don't like the
lgbtq community fine
don't go to don't go where they're at
actually you know what just stay in your
[ __ ] house honestly stay in your
[ __ ] house don't don't patreon don't
patronize businesses that have the pride
flag out don't don't go there
don't buy products from companies who
support
and who are allies
don't vote for people who want to make
sure that everyone's Liberty is
protected don't do that
that's what you can do in a democracy
now you're going to be drowned out
because you're a [ __ ] bonehead
and you're still believing stupid ass
[ __ ] that you're reading on the Q Anon
[ __ ] Facebook feed
about what freedom is look my freedom
allows me to go in the grocery store and
select between 56 different types of
peanut butter and 72 different types of
frozen pizza that's my freedom and
liberty America you're an idiot that's
not what freedom is dummy
but until you [ __ ] pluck your head
out of your ass and realize what Liberty
and freedom actually are then you'll
know but yesterday was a huge victory
for Liberty it's a huge victory
Nancy Pelosi was tweeting about it this
morning I'm sure they're going to get it
to the house floor now almost
immediately
and the president will sign this thing
and it just sends a signal
more than anything to those communities
that hey we're here with you
I don't have to believe what you believe
I don't have to feel the way you feel
but I I'm here with you for your Liberty
I am an ally in your Liberty I am an
ally in democracy
and that's what's most important I would
never stop some toothless redneck you
know wanting to marry his third cousin I
don't care you're in Arkansas do what
you want to do I don't give a [ __ ]
that's who you love fine by me whatever
go for it
go for it Skippy
I'm good with it I'm not gonna judge you
sure
I mean you know it's kind of weird but
whatever it's not my thing I'm not the
one marrying my third cousin though what
do I care
I mean I am in Missouri so you know
there was a good chance
that was a good chance yeah I mean we're
like The Loft Department above
you know Hillbilly Heaven down in
Arkansas
um
I'm just saying I hear Alabama likes
that kind of [ __ ] too look I'm getting
off track here
the point is this is that yesterday was
a huge there were huge victories in
democracy yesterday one of the biggest
victories out of the Senate
and I know the Stuart Rhodes being found
guilty uh puts the hots to put a lot
puts a lot of people in the hot seat
um I don't know if we'll see the proud
boys actually start to start to fold
now that they've seen this jury
absolutely not by any argument
whatsoever about uh them committing
sedition that it's them being Patriots
they didn't buy that at all they didn't
buy that [ __ ] that while we tried to
overturn the government because we're
Patriots no they didn't buy that [ __ ]
is that stupid [ __ ] argument it's
flimsy it's worthless toss it out and
the proud boys are probably we're
probably planning on making that
argument and that argument's not
probably going to fly in front of a jury
even a different jury in their trial
and it puts a lot of heat on this the
state elector scheme it really does this
puts the heat on that [ __ ]
investigation
um especially if that investigation has
Jack Smith as a special counsel and all
the January 6 elect evidence about to be
transferred to the doj which Jack Smith
is now going to receive
cooperate a lot of this a lot of this
state elector scheme that went on
all that's a victory
for our country
but no better Victory yesterday than the
one that happened in the Senate 61 votes
and really honestly I can't even believe
in this day and age in 2022
especially when their party runs around
can't stop talking about Freedom when
they don't know what it is really and
it's obvious with the vote yesterday
that there was only 61 Senators out of
161
that were willing to say yes yes you
should marry who you want to love and no
one should [ __ ] get in the way of
that
it doesn't matter race sex gender
whatever
you should marry you should get to I
mean you know we don't want the
Tennessee type marriage where you're
marrying underage girls they're [ __ ]
sicko
Chad but what two consenting adults that
they love each other it doesn't matter
who they are where they're from what
their skin color is what their religion
is
what their gender is sex is they should
be able to love each other and they
should be able to want the misery of
marriage sure
come on everyone knows this marriage is
difficult it's it's tough
but they should have the liberty of
getting that that tough relationship too
why not
stop trampling on people's freedoms just
because of who they are
and stop cheering when they get killed
because of who they are you [ __ ]
sickos
everybody I'm I'm I'm excited that it's
hump day it's Wednesday
we're getting closer and closer to the
month of December
which we have the Christmas holiday in
the month of December we took off
for Thanksgiving
a few days and it felt really good I
really appreciate the audience hanging
with us there as we took a few days off
for the holidays so we could recharge
our batteries we we go every single
weekday here Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and we simulcast from
the Mindless touch Facebook page and our
Facebook page we broadcast everywhere
and there's thousands of people that
watch this show every single day and I'm
so excited to have you and I'm so
excited we're getting into the month of
December
it just means a new year and a new
battle
for our democracy that's what it means
and we will keep going every single
weekday but I do want to tell you that
we are going to take a little bit of a
break around the Christmas holiday
we enjoyed our break for Thanksgiving
and we appreciate you you being being
patient with us
on that it felt good to recharge the
batteries so we're going to do that on
Christmas and we're going to do that on
New Year's we'll be announcing ahead of
time what that will look like so that
way you guys know when we'll have them
and when we won't
because I know a lot of you come here
every single day in the chat and I want
to make sure I want to make sure fake
games knows I don't want him waiting
around for a show thinking he can come
in and Troll and then he can't troll I
would be disappointing to him what kind
of Christmas would that be I don't think
Gabe
you [ __ ] all right everyone at make sure
to go over and follow us at Tony
Michaels pod on Twitter and make sure
again to subscribe here on YouTube we
put out the bonehead of the week pull
every single week and we're starting to
back up I know we were up for the
holiday last week starting to back up
this week bonehead of the week you'll be
able to vote you'll be able to decide
tomorrow and Friday in the second hour
as we do every week we will break it
down and make sure to download every
single episode too that would be a huge
favor if you go download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google whatever
your favorite directory is go check us
out there
also leave us a great review why you're
subscribing there you can follow us on
Twitch too you guys know that there's
more and more we gotta we're getting
we're gaining a bigger and bigger
audience over on Twitch I'm not sure why
I'm not sure what it is we just stream
over there and they they just they come
and
you just continue to come and there's
more and more people that watch live
there's more and more people that watch
it uh recorded you can go watch over
there for a few days
twitch is a little different than
YouTube I don't know I am still trying
to figure that out over there
but as the holiday season gets near make
sure to check out
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com grab you some
great Liberty merch over there it's
getting cold in the month of December
we've got the hoodies the zip up
sweatshirts and the sweatshirts over
there long sleeve tees we also got the
t-shirts and the coffee mugs and if
you're down in Florida you know you can
get oh you know it's probably quote cold
down there but you can also get you a
Rhonda Sanchez can go [ __ ] himself shirt
we're gonna get into the Rhonda Santa
season I believe
oh I'm telling you
we're definitely going to get into the
Rhonda Santa season uh coming next
spring I believe that's when he's going
to start to really figure out if he's
going to run or not so you might want to
get your gear ready so go to
store.dtonymichaels.com check out your
favorite merch everyone stick around
we'll be right back with the shitless
Roundup I got some videos I want to show
you don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose babblemaga Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
hump day hump day hump day
oh we got Jeremy Johnson being a bigot
in the uh Facebook Chat of course he is
morning
[Music]
[ __ ] bigot Jeremy Johnson I don't
know what he's talking about he's
talking about God or some [ __ ] oh my God
this my God that
[ __ ] out of here with that God [ __ ]
look I don't give a [ __ ] I really don't
care if you
it is Jeremy's Liberty to believe in God
it's his Liberty to believe that people
who don't believe in God are somehow
demons
it is not his Liberty on the other hand
to dictate to someone else what they can
and can't believe and you cannot you
cannot you cannot commit hate crimes
against those people because of that
either that's a thing you can't do it's
a thing you can't do and we shouldn't
allow it here in this country and I
believe that is the most significant
thing about this bill
and was passed
and I I you know but they didn't have to
pass this right they didn't have to
um
pass the respect of Marriage Act they
didn't have to do this
um the Supreme Court and overfeld is
ruled
that that gay marriage is legal
it's a thing that has that if you want
to be married to who you love you can be
married
that that is important
to everyone's Liberty even your own
listen I said this after the shooting at
Club Q
R Liberty
your Equity your equality in our society
depends is Reliant
on the lgbtq community the bipoc
community any any marginalized Community
women receiving their rights and Liberty
it is reliant on it
if we do not
as a democracy as a society
give Liberty to all people
yours is at risk
that's how this works that's why
progression actually happens
that's why
and I know progress scares you Jeremy I
understand this you you know you get
these insecurities about your manhood
which I'm going to show you
oh my God
excuse me I'm gonna show you a video
of Madison Gotham this is one of the
best videos best pieces of content this
little cook has ever made ever in the
history of his entire [ __ ] shitty
career
as a congressperson
is Madison Gotham gave his Sanchez did
you
yeah
did you see this video of of Madison
gothorne on the floor talking about hell
he's scared that masculinity is gone or
some [ __ ] I don't was it the one about
was it the soft masculinity or yes I saw
a brief clip and then I I was such a
goddamn cuck man he reminds me of Jeremy
here in the chat Jeremy's I I brought up
I brought up that uh that the Senate
which I think yesterday there was a lot
of good stuff for democracy but I
believe the Senate passing this bill six
with 61 votes yeah um is one of the most
significant things that happened
just just this year honestly I mean
let's also understand the two Advanced
Liberty right right yeah the the
interracial uh or the same yeah what
same-sex it's the respect from Aaron
Jack basically it it tears down the
defend Defense of Marriage Act which is
which is bigotry right right you're not
actually defending your marriage you're
you're making sure people can't get it
right like that's right yeah yeah you're
you know it's uh only I can have it and
not not this other group right me and
white men tell you what what is insane
and also very much of of what
the Republican party is is you've got
Senator Mitch McConnell
yeah
who is in an interracial marriage right
hand out it continues to be pointed out
by Nazis specifically the head Nazi well
I mean what do you expect when you when
you're like hey look I'm gonna make this
fun theme park for a bunch of bigots
and then the bigots become bigoted
against you what do you think's gonna
like what do you expect so when you're
when you when you're in an interracial
manner are you saying that Mitch
McConnell deserves all this and has
earned this is that what you're saying I
don't look I
it it it feels
I mean Mr Kyle's a terrible person
well that's an understatement yeah yeah
but
the idea that you would vote against
your own best interests like literally
you are married yeah but is it really
because here's what I believe that Mitch
McConnell thinks he's like look I've
already got my marriage and I'm a white
man and I'm the majority or the minority
leader in the Senate yeah but I'm a
senator I have the privilege you're not
going to be able to take this away from
me I'm gonna it's not about me it's
about you not having it but what's the I
mean that's that's like when we talked
months ago right about
uh overturning your OV wave right right
and then people being like well that's
it that's all they're gonna do and we're
like no no that's just one step I mean
you had people like uh cornyn when they
were going through the supreme court
hearing meetings and
randomly don't know why it's relevant
unless you're trying to overturn that
right and corn and bringing up hey well
what do you think about interracial
marriage huh how do you feel about this
one part of this this idea uh what if
you removed that right like why is that
even a discussion right we've been given
this right to marry whoever we want
right we've fought so hard for these
things for them to say you know what
yeah we shouldn't have really given that
in the first place so now we're just
gonna like take that one back and we're
gonna take that one back where it goes
like oh well you've got people like
Clarence Thomas just like kind of
unprompted bringing up uh same-sex
marriage who is also interracial
marriage what's funny is 61 Senators
just voted to protect his marriage right
exactly but it's one of those things
where you say okay great wait all right
these people vote against interracial
same-sex marriage
and then what's to stop the next round
of conservative Cooks to go through once
Mitch McConnell's out of office let's
say and then say oh you know what we're
going to invalidate all of these
marriages that were put in place so if
you're married to anyone that wasn't of
your same race you got to get a DNA test
we're gonna have to sequence that genome
to prove that you're actually not the
same group and then if that is true that
you're different then well looks like
that is null and void and then you know
I you know then you could go down a dark
trail of like well uh now you're gonna
have to back pay all those taxes and
those benefits you got from being
married and all those benefits that you
received from actually sharing uh you
know the same you know tax filing
like there's a lot of things where
somebody says oh that'll never happen
and you're like oh no look it starts
with this they want to take away
contraceptives they want to take away
this they realize you know something I
realized last night when I was writing a
new what was that is that uh justice
Alito quoted a 17th century English
judge who is known for holding Witch
Trials and very very deranged debunked
um ideas on a rape okay you know what's
another
uh another quote or another phrase that
I want to pull out of 17th century
England
hmm
Hell hath no fury like a woman scorned
okay that's what it is same time period
same region of the world you would think
that if you're going to quote one thing
that you would learn the lesson of
something that was around that same time
period and and
thankfully
we did not
um
we we did not lose more of our democracy
by having people come in and want to
take more more way more rights right we
had women that fought up and said okay
you know what that was far enough we're
not going to do that but it is one of
those things where it's like if you take
away these rights right they go against
same-sex they go again interracial they
go against contraceptives they go
against this they begin to tuck away if
they're like if this is true then this
can also be true that we take away these
things one we all we we saw this um uh
the referendums not just in States like
Michigan
um but also referendum State like Kansas
States like Kentucky voted for
Republicans but still said no you're
take get your [ __ ] hands off my
[ __ ] rights right look you can you
can be a bigot fine whatever you want to
do if if you want to hold those views
and you want to you don't want people to
get gay married and you don't want to be
married in a gay marriage fine whatever
or an interracial marriage whatever it
is that you're insecure about Jeremy
because you are insecure Jeremy if if
fine whatever but you can't [ __ ] with me
you can't [ __ ] with what I want because
you start [ __ ] with you start [ __ ]
with my rights or someone else's rights
you start [ __ ] with everybody's
rights you start taking away everybody's
[ __ ] everybody's [ __ ] because once you
apply that you say well this person
doesn't have a right and like well then
what's to say this person should have
that and then you go down this road of
then you the person Jeremy Johnson fake
Gabe who thought you had these rights
turns out when you wake up you don't
have those rights well you know and I I
brought this up because I live in
Missouri and you know we're kind of the
loft apartment above you know Hillbilly
Heaven in Arkansas I hear Alabama's kind
of the same way I've never I've been
through Alabama but never stopped you
too long I stopped in Birmingham once we
stayed in the Econo Lodge holy [ __ ] it
was nasty but you know what is
Birmingham what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do we're on the road you
know you gotta you gotta stop where you
gotta stop but Arkansas
is Hill is Hillbilly Heaven right and
um Arkansas I'm not up I'm not opposed
to people in Arkansas if they want to
marry the third cousin fine [ __ ] it
whatever you want to do I actually this
may be one of the most controversial
things I ever say but I'll tell you
maybe not but I'll tell you that I
actually I actually think polygamy
should I I don't think we should be
outlogging polygamy if if multiple
people want to be in a relationship why
the [ __ ] are you stopping them from
doing that now there is bounds of the
law right there are bounds of the law it
doesn't matter
um if if it's polygamy or or or if it's
or if it's the the the the third cousin
thing right if you're if you're trying
to marry underage children that's a
different thing Republicans you can't do
that yeah you can't we're not going to
let you do that
but outside of that that you know that
right that guard rail that we as
societies say no you can't be pedophiles
yeah just a bare minimum like hey let's
not do that you know right but but
outside of that parameter I don't I
don't find it offensive that three
people or four people want to be in a
relationship what the [ __ ] do I care
what the [ __ ] do I get what has it got
to do with me again it really comes down
to those people Republicans who say uh
no that's not fair that's not fair no
one wants to marry me no one wants to
date me and nobody gets to marry those
people nobody gets to date anyone you
know it's just that's really where it's
at right because because these
Republican dudes these white dudes like
Jeremy Johnson he's just really upset
that a really attractive gay guy
wouldn't want to marry that [ __ ]
right and he's really upset he's even
more upset that a woman doesn't find him
attractive that he can that he can that
you know because he's really gotta hold
these in Securities inside of like a
closed area maybe
it's just saying to the to the old like
hypothetical it's like well if there was
only two people left on Earth and you
were one of them and I was one of them
like that person the other person that
woman or that man look at the situation
at Jeremy Johnson other people like you
know that come from that side and that
way if they can they look at them and go
uh I would much rather die than you know
[ __ ] fornicate or humans will go
extinct humans will go they're like look
if if the if if the future of this
planet
depends on us even though or it might be
a man and man or a woman or woman right
they're like look
um I'm out deuces you know I will go
find a place to enjoy my life in my own
peace and do whatever the [ __ ] I want
without you having to creep over a bunch
of rocks trying to figure out what I'm
doing and trying to tell me that it's
illegal right so but I'm not against I'm
again I'm not against even polygamy and
a lot of people like
what adult people what the [ __ ] that
Gannon can't do that's ain't got nothing
to do with me so why do I give a [ __ ]
right that's that may be their religion
or their non-religion or whatever they
want to do that's that's up to them I'm
not I am not going to get in the way
I have a bunch of people having like an
orgy marriage it's not it's not a thing
that I'm concerned about and that's the
core of it you know really like
regardless of marriage regardless if you
love regardless of what you want to do
like all of these things
are completely rooted in the idea that
Republicans
are envious in many ways and jealous of
things they do not have and what they
say is well if I can't have those things
then neither can you and again it
doesn't have to be marriage it could be
anything if there's anything that the
Republican Party says I kind of feel the
same way and I want those things but so
so much of this party is rooted in
hatred or bigotry or violence or mocking
or whatever it might be you know they're
like I can't have those things I mean
maybe that's why you find so many of
those Republicans like
hidden and and they don't feel
comfortable coming out of the closet or
or being in a relationship or they end
up being pedophiled I mean because they
couldn't pick up a dude at a bar kind of
thing well yeah I mean it really but
again it is like Jeremy here he says he
says man and a man
doesn't
neat make babies yeah and I literally
but I literally that's what he was
saying dummy uh very good real Gabe he's
just Gabe he's not a real game fake gave
his unit
um this will destroy the human race
that's that's actually I think that's I
if you go back and watch I think that's
what the [ __ ] he was saying man but
here's the thing Jeremy
I know that you're mad that if you went
to a bar and you found a man attractive
which I'm sure you have I mean I went to
a bar and like hey that's a good looking
dude yeah Ryan Reynolds oh man I I
listen I I I am definitely a
heterosexual male but I'll tell you
something if I had the chance to [ __ ]
Brad Pitt I think I just might consider
it I'm just saying it I'm just saying so
Jeremy if you're listening you know and
and the internet trolls of your
listening you can go ahead and spread
that around the internet I definitely
would [ __ ] I might consider Leonardo
Gabriel depending on the dad bod
situation you know what I mean
[ __ ] better get fit before I
[ __ ] and I'm gonna be picky look I'm
gonna be picky if I'm gonna do this now
Jeremy I'm sure is not that picky about
the dudes that he sees at a bar like he
gets all up in his Fields you know
and I'm sure that it really upsets him
that no one pays attention to him
because you know a [ __ ] woman ain't
gonna pay attention to this [ __ ]
anymore let alone let alone a dude that
he might be interested in and God forbid
God forbid that somebody like Jeremy and
other people tell other people how they
should love care for live right these
are things when you again when you bring
it down to his core who the [ __ ] cares
that person is living their life
and you have no reason to I mean other
than if it's something illegal right you
know totally
but at its core Jeremy Johnson
that's gay this guy did I mean you know
he might just they Gabe you might take a
back seat Jeremy here this is just the
stupidest [ __ ] I've ever heard in my
life the core of it is sin that's what
you again I can't [ __ ] stress this
enough Jeremy that's what you believe
that's not your opinion that is what you
believe your belief is not an opinion it
doesn't get to work its way into policy
and what I mean by that here's what I
mean by that is your belief that two
dudes
being in love picking each other up at a
bar maybe going home and [ __ ] who
knows who knows there's all sorts of
things
right right it's their consensual sex is
their Heavens you believe that it's sin
you believe that it's sin and that is
something that you can do you add the
Liberty to believe that that is sin and
you do not have to you do not have to
live out your fantasies that you hold
deep down inside your subconscious you
can believe that it's sin and you do not
have to act when you see a dude at a bar
and you think he's really attractive and
maybe he's into you maybe he's not I
don't know but this idea
at the end of your statement here you
say taboo but media wants to normalize
dude gay people have been around since
humans have been around dummy
this idea that all of a sudden all of a
sudden there's there's men who are
dressing and drag and and gay people you
are a dumb son of a [ __ ] man I know I
know you've held weird insecurities your
entire life and you question your
sexuality that's why you're typing in
this [ __ ] in the chat you can't help
yourself I get it I understand whatever
but here's the thing
is that there is no normalization of it
man these people these people have been
in hiding their entire lives because of
[ __ ] bigots like you and because now
they have more allies than they have
bigots beaten at their door they feel
comfortable being who they are out in
public So when you say normalization
what you mean is it makes you feel you
in particular feel uncomfortable when
you see something that gives you
insecurities about yourself that's not
their problem that's a you problem and
then it got nothing to do with anyone
else's Liberty so you have the Liberty
to have your insecurities and have your
little stupid beliefs about Sin and the
feelings that you get at a bar when you
see a good looking dude I know that's
probably what's happening and those
insecurities that you have I know that's
probably what's going on but you have
the right and the Liberty to suppress
those things you have the right and the
Liberty to believe Eve believe that the
that is sin and you do not have to act
on those things but you cannot prevent
someone else
from acting the way they want to act or
being who they want to be and also I
mean something that people bring up in
the in the chat which I think is is
important to you know either not sure
Jeremy believes in science but in the
animal kingdom there are many many
animals that that that have sex you're
you're saying you're saying dude dogs
like to [ __ ] dude dogs sometimes you
know they have a dream it's it is it is
you're saying that some animals yeah
engaging homosexual lying activities
there's all reasons why they do it
whether it's uh for sake of feeling
closer in a knit Community protection
whatever it might be there's many
reasons but the other thing too is
Jeremy Johnson and other people from the
magazine Republicans want to quote Oh
well yeah gay Penguins is another one
they uh same-sex will it's like it's
just like a a a a really known thing
that penguins are gay
uh they'll uh they they will they can
the same sex will then take care of baby
penguins oh so they basically just like
take it in so it's this whole adoption
it's because the male penguin actually
is the one who who is the quote mother
of the of the children but what I mean
by that is is in in in our society it is
the woman who has to be the right mother
because this is the thing let me tell
you this and I'll point this out and
Jeremy's probably one of these guys I
have these friends right they got kids
and and I'm like what what are you what
are you doing this weekend like oh I'm
babysitting the kids I'm like babies
they're your kids you're not babysitting
your kids they're your [ __ ] kids your
watch you're with the kids you're not
babysitting yeah but you know my wife
usually takes care of them I'm like God
good God you're not babysitting you're
you're there father dummy but this is
this is and and this is the [ __ ] I'm
gonna show you this clip in the [ __ ]
let's round it I'm Madison Gotham this
clip is brilliant like just bring it
displays all of Jeremy Johnson's
insecurities right out in the open uh
and really it's just it's Madison
cawthorne who is a weak white male
trumped up cuck but there's so many of
them out there and it displays
beautifully exactly their insecurities
all in one right two minute clip but
also you know you've got you've got uh
Jeremy Johnson who clearly you know
follows the Bible you know I'm sure I'm
sure it supports Marjorie Taylor green
and the fact that she broke the Ten
Commandments but whatever you know
probably loves Trump in his three
marriages exactly right you know Affairs
adults different sets of children yeah
yeah I'm sure the other the other thing
is when you've got someone who is like
so ingrained and believes in religion
you begin to ask yourself well what do
you think about Adam and Eve right you
you believe this idea that God took a
rib and made Eve got it right they could
you know have sex and populate the the
world well if you start with two people
and then you have children and then you
have to ask yourself well
are those kids gonna have sex when they
grow up or are the parents gonna have
sex with those kids there's a lot of
questions that bring up a lot of hey hey
you're really you're really you're
really throwing wrenches in Jeremy's
system here I mean I just I just figured
I'd at least bring it up so that maybe
later Jeremy could go oh wait it started
with two people did the parents have sex
with their own kids at all yeah
maybe they had sex with animals I don't
know who knows who knows it's a it's a
great story though Jeremy it's great
stories
and that that imaginary book you got all
right let's let's do this because I want
to show Gabe this clip everyone let's go
to the shitless Roundup where we round
up all the Tweety tweets and training
twins why those tweets still exist
let's let's go to the [ __ ] let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the show you've
reached part of the show we round up all
the Tweety tweets trends of the day as
long as Twitter still exists yay um
before we get to this video of Madison
gothorne yeah what's what's your over
under on um Twitter being dropped from
the Apple Store you think it's uh uh you
think it's a possibility or you think
this is just [ __ ] that elon's trying to
get Tim Cook's attention I actually I
actually watched a bunch of Elon simps
thinking Tim Cook was trying to get
elon's attention I'm like oh my God yeah
this book is not tweeting about Elon
Musk right he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
Elon Musk I think I think that this
whole thing is a huge distraction tactic
I mean I mean Oh you mean on elon's part
yeah yeah I mean I'll call Elon out
whenever I can to say like the guy has a
terrible management strategy he fired
people you know you know for the
Republicans out there there who say oh
well we gotta control this child
pornography and child abuse that's
online well if that was so important
that Elon Musk said oh that's priority
number one and then cuts the team in
half and says good luck trying to do now
twice the amount of work if not more you
know it really shows you that the guy
doesn't really care about what the
[ __ ] going on now whether he's trying
to intentionally destroy this thing for
tax purposes or what have you but this
whole idea
it's been interesting this whole idea
about like oh censorship by a private
company right a private company
you know and whether people are oh it's
a publicly traded no you [ __ ] idiot
okay look Apple they're their own they
they they have a certain terms and
conditions right they've got a terms of
service that they have they're just like
Twitter well at least used to but
there's a terms of service that Apple
says and they have things like oh you
have to make sure that your app if you
want to be in the App Store you have to
have moderation you have to make sure
that you have these certain tools to
make sure that there's not spamming or
scams or other things that can make
right you can't harm you can't harm the
Apple customers with your app that's
what Apple's trying to prevent exactly
if you have this app it's the same
reason why parlor got pulled from the
App Stores because they found out that
parlor didn't have any moderation
protocols in place and you had people
that were trying to [ __ ] storm in the
capital and plan the Insurrection and
they're like actually we can't have this
and the reason why they let parlor back
on is because parlor fixed that problem
right for some degree to Apple
satisfaction right right and so you look
at Twitter and right now you've got Elon
Musk that is firing people who would be
in terms of moderation you got other
people who are I mean you've got uh that
the former head of trust and safety he
was doing a panel yesterday and
literally discussed this idea
a fake game hey you just you just don't
don't disappoint man yeah I was gonna I
was gonna replace Jeremy with fake gave
here today but yeah he doesn't
disappoint me yeah but you you look at
uh what's going on and there is a
possibility there's a very good
possibility that Apple does look at
what's going on at at Twitter and says
you know what we we don't feel like uh
this app is the safest because I mean
they also can analyze to some degree
what's going on with the app right they
obviously don't have like complete
insight into certain metrics but they
can observe well they are required I
mean Twitter is required when they
submit to the App Store to certain data
right I mean yeah yeah there are certain
data that can be pulled out right
there's certain data to be like that
Apple has access to because that's part
of it I mean they can't go through and
like analyze right they can't spy on
them but there's certain data points
that have to be provided to Apple uh
fake Gabe says here musk about to drop
in oh Jesus Christ now musk is a
journalist Jesus Christ must about to
drop info about Twitter colluding with
the Biden Administration about stifling
Free Speech okay hey fake Gabe I don't
know if you know what the [ __ ]
definition of free speech is but here it
is Elon Musk has the freedom to
absolutely destroy Twitter he owns it
now he can [ __ ] destroy it by letting
all kinds of Nazis on his platform he
can [ __ ] destroy it if he wants to he
does not he does not have to moderate
that app but it is Apple's free speech
with their customers to tell Twitter and
Elon Musk to [ __ ] off now
the reason why what you're saying is the
bad Administration and Twitter were
colluding is because Twitter had a
certain terms of service and a certain
moderation policy before the bonehead
bought it that's their free speech it
was their company I don't know if you
know what free speech is but it's not
just your speech right your speech is
not the only speech that is protected
Apple's speech is protected Twitter
rather it was when it was a publicly
traded company or under Elon
uh uh the the actual customers and the
users on the app they have [ __ ]
freedom of speech dude you really are
[ __ ] dumb you really are [ __ ] dumb
and I wish I wish that we could get to a
place in in this world that people
understand what free speech is and what
social media is they are not the same
thing those are not one and the same
they're not they're not saying it's also
the idea like this is fake Gabe is is
swimming in a in a q Anon pool right now
right the idea that Elon Musk is gonna
drop this oh man you can't wait until
the next musk drop okay you gotta wait
for it he's gonna drop a bunch of Intel
that's not happening okay because well
and even if he does even if he does who
gives a [ __ ] right what what what
possibly could Elon Musk drop that is
going to shatter freeze that is going to
make free speech Free Speech again which
it already is I don't know
I don't know if you know this fake Gabe
but almost every single one of the
people that you listen to and you come
type in their [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] that
they tell you to type in this chat
every one of them has a book on Amazon
every one of them has a [ __ ] YouTube
channel every one of them's on Rumble
everyone was on on some sort of social
media platform saying the stupid [ __ ]
you're saying even here you say that's a
lie the majority of all the rhetoric was
on Facebook again you're not
understanding you're not getting it free
speech is not social media social media
is not free speech they are not the same
thing they're two different
[ __ ] I mean yes can social
media something you post on there be
free speech yeah sure whatever and can
free speech be a form of social media
sure but they are not the same thing
those two things are not the same dummy
you need to [ __ ] pluck your head out
of your ass and then maybe we'll get to
a situation but prove it wrong he says
what do you mean well here here prove it
right if you have if you have this idea
that Elon Musk is about to drop
something crazy news oh yeah he's got
some Q Anon [ __ ] going on here see this
something about colluding with a with
the US government he's got some kind of
[ __ ] he's got some kind of [ __ ]
um show me conspiracy theory here's
here's the other thing too is that the
federal government the federal
government that has been the federal
government
for less than two years it's the same
one that was before him dummy same
[ __ ] yeah there's different
heads and different departments but all
the bureaucrats all that big government
[ __ ] you talk about all the same of our
the Deep State it's all the same
bureaucrats same [ __ ] as a
trump Administration and also I'll just
give you this here we'll we can move on
to Madison cawthorne the last thing I
want to say to fake Gabe is if you have
you ready I'm going to say it slowly
just listen slowly yeah if you have
evidence or proof of Elon Musk saying
that he's about to drop a bunch of intel
on Biden colluding or collaborating or
working together with Twitter to
suppress uh Free Speech or your voice or
anyone in the Americans that you know I
just
just just put it in the chat okay if you
can show me
Elon Musk in writing that he sent or in
an interview that he did and said oh man
I've got all these all these all this
evidence all this proof that shows Elon
Musk which shows that Twitter uh uh you
know worked with the Biden
Administration if you can find anything
of him saying that in text or audio or
video
feel free to share it yeah we'll we'll
play the video sure we'll play the video
um
it sucks to suck Gabe
and real Gabe I know that you suck and
it sucks to suck so
more power to you man
um and Q Anon is a hell of a drug I mean
it's a hell of a drug I mean people are
still hooked on that [ __ ] baby talk
about um hell the drugs and sex cocaine
field orgies now I'm here is Madison
cawthorn himself this is the video that
I wanted to show you on the floor now
remember this guy lost
his primary right so they didn't want
him to be the candidate
um apparently he's got his office
cleaned out so I'm not sure why he's
still in Washington I haven't figured
that out yet I mean he's I haven't seen
much of him uh lately
when he looked like [ __ ] Mac's
Headroom on the night that dead out of
Mar-A-Lago right yeah yeah you know what
I bet it is I bet he came to Washington
to his empty office to vote against just
to vote against the respect America well
we also know that while cawthorne has
been in office he has missed more votes
than anyone else and this guy is a
[ __ ] freshman Congressman right that
is not something you want to do because
you want to prove to say like yeah I've
been here every day I'm sure I missed a
couple things for some private stuff or
this or that or whatever but I was there
all the time I had a proxy I voted I did
this I did that but when you've got a
guy that doesn't show up and seems like
he didn't really care because he suffers
from the same thing Lauren Bogart
Marjorie Taylor green [ __ ] suffer
from they only want fame and fortune
in their office position they don't
really care about actually helping their
constituents they only care about the
way are you saying are you saying a
congressperson gets elected to do [ __ ]
for their constituents I know it's crazy
it's crazy come on man it's it's about
it's about having that Twitter account
man oh right the check mark which now
anyone can have which also it's November
30th and Elon said on November 29th that
the new system will be in play oh yeah
so today today or yesterday no he's it
was supposed to be November 29th he
might have said they were going to push
it because and then here's the solution
to their uh their verified their
verified check problem
uh they're just going to give people
different colors so now it's just gonna
be a rainbow of check marks so it should
have just been that in the beginning yes
and just yeah I mean we talked about
this you remember we talked about this
when they did the stupid official thing
which they have on some of them still I
was like why the [ __ ] don't they just
have different [ __ ] for whatever
thing that you're doing like if you buy
the Twitter blue fine and you want a
verified check or whatever why don't you
just make a different little check mark
different color different you know you
can make it a V for verified or you
could give the blue check to the Twitter
blue and give the V to actual verified
accounts and you can do all sorts of
things with this there's a lot of things
that they could do and they they they've
been working for a month now on this
verified problem that they predicted
which again he caused it's a verified
problem that he caused right
I mentioned that why didn't you just why
didn't he just why didn't he just raise
the price of Twitter blue literally that
is the it's the exact same thing with
just a Mark that you're paying because
now what now it now it just hey look
there's an idiot who's paying Elon eight
dollars right right like why didn't they
but it really just comes down to and we
can we can uh we can jump into the into
the other video later on but the head
and Trust head of trust and safety who
resigned literally said
we knew this was gonna happen we
predicted this was gonna because that's
our job we look at these potential
problems or or you know introducing
these these new features into the app
and we look at them and we say great
based on these other things we model
this to perform this way and we believe
that if we force this in it's going to
cause a lot of problems and a lot of
those problems they predicted but the
person who makes a decision at the end
of the day is the chief twit which is
Elon and he made a decision that was
we're going to force it through [ __ ] I
think he's [ __ ] yeah
and uh anyway so you it's you know
you've got all these [ __ ] incompetent
people who are really just pushed by
their own ego and and Madison cawthorne
is another person who is really just
using their platform as a [ __ ] bully
pulpit to talk about soft masculinity or
talk about the [ __ ] woke mob or uh
[ __ ] Libs this and libs that and they
don't do anything to actually help
people just like Elon isn't actually
helping people on Twitter Madison
cawthorne and the rest of these
Republicans who have you know a mere
month
or plus left in their in their position
are not helping constituents they don't
[ __ ] care they're not there they
don't actually vote and when they do
vote it's on the most trivial dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] possible the craziest part
here about this little speech that he's
gonna give
is that this is going to be one of the
last things that he says on record
that's the weirdest part to me like not
not a not a thank you for sending me
here and giving me the opportunity to
serve you none of that [ __ ] yeah but he
couldn't save I actually served you well
right well I mean that would be a lie I
mean he'll try to well I mean why
wouldn't he lie though why the [ __ ]
wouldn't this guy lie I mean he's lost
everything he lost his uh his his
wife he lost his government position he
lost any sort of sense of credibility
that he had when he came in he's like
I'm a history buff and every time he
[ __ ] spoke he missed he misquoted
some person from history you know what
he meant to say is he likes Nazis and he
knows Nazis ah yes that's right I mean
he did he did go to Hitler's nest and
he's like oh I love this place this is
my favorite place on Earth this is my
favorite place on Earth all right let's
listen to this
nincompoop this cuck oh my God this is
so cocky let's listen
our young men are taught that weakness
and strength that delicacy is desirable
and that being a soft metrosexual is
more valuable than training the Mind
Body and Soul
what what I I can't I can't even tell
you like literally literally he wrote
these words out to say in one of his
last [ __ ] speeches he's gonna give on
record he wrote this [ __ ] out to say it
what the [ __ ] soft metrosexual listen
I I
know several of this night it's this
feels like a really old phrase this
metrosexual thing yeah but I've known
metrosexuals right you know what a
metrosexual is right
well what's a metrosexual to you like
what what do you feel like that's the
the definition I mean the one that they
people go by is like oh that like I've
been called a metrosexual before like
somebody commented your example somebody
commented on my eyebrows okay my
eyebrows which they're sexy man which is
the way they are which is the way they
are right and yeah let's show let's show
people the the yeah it's just the this
is the way they naturally are all right
and I had people online that attacked oh
by the way uh speaking of eyes speaking
speaking of eye patch yeah
but I had people that were like oh man
Gabe totally plucks his eyebrows one who
[ __ ] cares right who cares it's my
body my choice I have to trim mine I
have to trim mine I mean they get a
little long so you gotta trim them but
by Def well by some people's definition
they would be like oh that's so [ __ ]
that's that's so [ __ ] Mo that's a
Metro oh my God because you is that what
is that the so it's a mo is that there
no well that one was more specifically
someone call me like oh I'm homosexual
oh I see but it's like I don't do that
but what metrosexual doesn't mean
homosexual right I mean no no not at all
but it's the it's the how they conflate
the two right and so it's the idea that
you're like
any sense of oh I like the way I mean
they that's what they do they they will
confuse the two and say oh a metrosexual
is someone who is actually
um homosexual right they don't they
don't they they don't uh wait they're
unable so you're saying the insecures
like like because it's like it's like
look you're someone you're someone who's
heterosexual right you're not whatever
you're heterosexual and you have good
taste uh you're young you you've got you
know you you wear nice clothes you've
got a good fashion sense right you take
care you well that's what I always
thought of metrosexual was I didn't
think it had anything to do with your
sexuality other than no it doesn't it
doesn't but what I'm saying is they
conflate the two so they look they look
at the two and they say oh metrosexual
homosexual the same thing because they
don't actually have the intellect to say
oh actually just means that this person
is this and that person's that that's
the thing it's just it's just somebody
it's a heterosexual person who does
their best to look good and fashionable
and here's the thing I actually would
believe like from what we've seen from
Madison Gotham other than one video and
I'll explain myself here
that he was a metrosexual like you know
he wears really nice clothes he you know
he looks like he gets his hair cut three
times a week right yeah he it looks like
the dude Dallas's him I've never smelt
him but I would imagine you could smell
the [ __ ] from a mile away from
the cologne that he's wearing oh yeah
right uh you know oh he definitely trims
his eyebrows and he probably has them
professionally done you know he's not
like me where he doesn't no he doesn't
trim his his butt though we know that
that's what I was gonna say the only
reason why I I wouldn't call him a
metrosexual because I would imagine if
you had a [ __ ] a butt a butt Mohawk
like that yeah you would definitely get
that sumbitch waxed if you were
mentosexual so I actually maybe he's
borderline and maybe that's why he's so
[ __ ] insecure here but but what gets
me is when he says a soft metrosexual
that's why I think he really truly
believes he is one and he's a hard
metrosexual you know what I mean I carry
guns and I I I'm a bigot so I'm a hard
metrosexual not one of them soft mentors
that's what I believe he's saying he's
like maybe he could very well be that's
what he means but there's hard
metrosexuals but I would also just go
back to what the [ __ ] is he talking
about I don't know who right he actually
uses the word metrosexual anymore number
one I don't know know I I mean other
than I haven't heard I haven't heard
that term outside of somebody calling me
metrosexual online I'm like whatever but
I haven't actually heard someone say in
conversation eyebrows look at the
eyebrows yeah it's the eye I can't I I
just don't know like another time when
you would just passively throw or
casually throw that into a conversation
because the way that I look at is like
oh that person wears nice clothes that
person cares for their skin or their
hair or whatever the [ __ ] it is who the
[ __ ] cares because that's the other
thing again it really comes back to this
idea of like what is this matter to you
this person does this thing when their
body you guys want to [ __ ] talk about
your body your choice all that stuff but
when it comes to another person a woman
a man whoever it might be
you're like oh no you can't do that and
if you do that I'm gonna [ __ ] make
fun of you and it's like wait what
what's going on here what the [ __ ] is
going on here so yeah it just I I don't
think I've really heard that in a
conversation in maybe in the last like
15 20 years it's been a long time since
this word is surfaced but and I didn't
mean to get off on a tangent here about
the word metrosexual but I really needed
to to iron that out let's listen to the
rest of the insecurity that Madison
Gotham pukes up here social media has
weakened us siphoning our men of their
will to fight to rise in a noble manner
Square their jaws and charge once more
into the breach of life than what they
love
so on this person it's a disaster I
asked the young men in this nation a
question
will you sit behind a screen while the
story tales of your forefathers become
myth this is coming from a person that
all he wants is to be a [ __ ] social
media influencer what what the [ __ ] is
this this is the same guy this is this
this is the [ __ ] same this guy one is
a predator so he can go shut the [ __ ] up
but this guy Madison cawthorne okay if
you don't know the story about Madison
go look it up go or go check it out look
it up this kid lied about getting into
the Naval Academy okay after he got into
this accident he was like oh I was
supposed to go to the Naval Academy but
now I can't because I'm now a uh uh I'm
a I'm a paraplegic and then it was
turned out that oh no he had been
rejected beforehand so he he attempted
to almost have the Stolen Valor but
couldn't quite get away with it because
he never actually was able to serve
because he wasn't actually admitted when
he would had full capability his body
then so he wants to play victim there so
it's funny to me that this guy wants to
go oh we [ __ ] storm the Forefront all
this and our forefathers become a myth
you don't even know the history of our
forefathers and any time you [ __ ]
quote someone you misquote the year you
misquote the phrase you misquote the
person if anything Madison cawthorne is
history okay I look at that as a guy who
is irrelevant who doesn't say anything
of Merit and when he does talk he's
projecting his own [ __ ] weird
insecurities and desires because at the
end of the day the guy doesn't have
anything to add of value to anything
that's going on specifically when it
comes to holding a government position
and here he is talking about soft hard
[ __ ] metrosexuals and oh they're
going to be this and that and keyboard
shut the [ __ ] up social social media is
a ruining men I would I would say that I
would say that more more people from gen
Z who might who might be like you know
what I'm not the traditional this or
that I'm my own thing and I don't give a
[ __ ] what you say those are the people
that took you out of office those are
the people that made sure that there
wasn't a red wave those are the people
that actually defended democracy to make
sure that this fascist regime from the
Republican Party didn't actually break
through like they all thought it was
going to so when you've got this guy
complaining about this and that he's
really I feel like he's targeting a
certain group of people
who actually you know
think that all those should have all
those soft metrosexuals out there listen
this this [ __ ]
is talking about [ __ ] he has no clue he
has no clue about masculinity this is
the guy with the [ __ ] tree punching
video and he thought it was so cool that
he posted it on social media and here's
this guy same guy claiming that social
media is taking away men's manlihood
seems like projection much let's listen
to the rest of this nonsense or will you
stand Resolute against the dying light
of America's golden age will you reclaim
your masculinity will you become a man
to be feared to be respected to be
looked up to or you let this nation's
Next Generation be its final generation
why does a man why does a man have to be
feared why did why why what the [ __ ] are
you people talking about stop it just be
you just do you Jeremy Johnson in the
chat just be you man if you want to hit
on a guy in a bar do that do that don't
be insecure about it don't be
insecurement don't worry if Madison
cawthorne thinks you're a soft
metrosexual it's okay it's okay to be
yourself it really is in this country
I'll fight for your [ __ ] Liberty yeah
I'll [ __ ] yell and scream at the top
of my lungs to make sure you have it for
sure and I will I also want to point out
that
people like Madison cawthorne that push
this idea of masculinity and [ __ ] you
got to be this [ __ ] big bro there are
literally studies
literally studies
that connect this idea of expressing
your masculinity and then also the the
correlation with uh unaliving yourself
and so in that you've got people that
want to push this oh [ __ ] tough tough
bro guy and PPU [ __ ] shoot my guns
and all this [ __ ] and you can't show
emotion you can't emote feelings and cry
and do all this stuff you can't actually
show that you're a human p a person that
has empathy and then when you find that
out you also realize that oh there's
actually a direct correlation between
those people and pushing that ideology
and pushing that way of thinking and
then young people who are more
susceptible or more vulnerable who might
say oh you know what life's not worth
living and then they take their own life
because of this idea of you got to be
tough and you can't show your minds and
if you are you're [ __ ] weak yeah but
it's all part of this white male trumped
up I'm I'm oppressed type [ __ ] when it's
not even close to the truth and I'll
show you another
um example of thousands of years here's
another example of this you know um you
talk about you talk about [ __ ] you
talk about you talk about a weirdo
and soft holy [ __ ] we uh the Surfs have
been posting more and more videos of
Matt Walsh uh in his car these [ __ ]
videos are weird
but this one's from Michelle I'm having
comment and I'm go with the cough drops
again yeah I gotta go I I ran through my
ludens this week or this weekend so I
have to go I got to go to Rite Aid to go
buy a new one I still got a few glutens
here at the desk
um just in case like today I've started
coughing it the weather changed here it
was warm yesterday the win game it got
cold so I think that
I think that has a lot to do with it but
here is Matt Walsh
talking about history you know you said
Madison Gotham is a historian
um here's Matt Walsh's version
of history with Native Americans this is
[ __ ] gross of course because he's
puking it up but oh my God this is
let's listen simplified myth now told
not just the children but hammered into
everybody's head
is a story of evil barbaric white people
who came here and just immediately
carried out a genocide against peaceful
Indians who okay first off because they
did right well but here's the thing is
not two seconds into this clip he starts
talking about [ __ ] grooming kids
again like this guy is absolutely 100
wants to groom every child he has ever
seen not seen because he cannot focus on
anything else but grooming children it
is [ __ ] weird man that he is like
look it is it it is your hypnotizing
children when you're telling them lies
that are not that are the truth it's
[ __ ] weird because what he's saying
here
number one he calls uh indigenous people
Indians that's intentional because he's
a [ __ ] bigot listen the reason why
they're not indians is because
Christopher Columbus is a bonehead and
this was not the Indies he did not he
did not land in in anywhere near India
and that is also why he's like oh I
discovered idiots it's like no you were
nowhere close to India right because
you're a terrible [ __ ] right
Navigator and you're just a rapist and
you know I guess you could say
Christopher Columbus was a Matt Walsh of
his time let's let's continue to listen
to the [ __ ] the the lies and the
bigotry here it's it is it is something
else and I'll tell you why it's white
supremacy here and I'll tell you why who
never did a single thing to deserve or
provoke any of the violence visited upon
them
the claim that we stole land from Native
Americans from some group called quote
Native Americans or quote indigenous
people is incoherent there never was any
homogeneous group of natives occupying
this land before the settlers got here
you are this [ __ ] guy again this is
the white supremacy part right what what
he is saying here
is that they had no borders they had no
governments but they did they did and
they didn't their society and their
culture didn't own things they didn't
rape and pillage things like white
people did and still do dummy they
didn't see like imaginary borders
because they wanted to own property like
you do right like our society does
that's not how that's not what it was
about the land was their culture the
land was their society they didn't need
a [ __ ] imaginary line to dictate to
them for their manhood to say that they
owned something or didn't own something
but this is why it's white supremacy is
because what Matt Walsh is going to say
here and and I watched this clip already
but what he's going to say here is
the reason why our country's better is
because of white people and the reason
why I've heard that before indigenous
people uh it's it now he doesn't say it
outright but that's what he's saying
here and the reason why that the
indigenous peoples Society didn't last
is because their society was inferior
and the white Society is is superior
that's what he's saying listen okay it's
not like the whole country was was was
uh was uh uh occupied by this one group
that we would call Native Americans not
Jesus there were rather disparate and
warring tribes that waged Wars of
conquest and extermination against each
other and had been doing so for
centuries before we arrived these but
you can't be more specific because there
is no coherent chain of custody for this
allegedly stolen Land There was for
thousands of years rather there were no
Deeds there were no Deeds to the land
they didn't see Matt Walsh does not does
not clearly on understand that the
indigenous people of this country before
white people came here and stole it from
them the land
they didn't see that they owned the land
they didn't have ownership of the land
they lived with the land that was part
of their culture he does not understand
culture he clearly does not and he
clearly does not want to understand
other people's culture at all or and and
try to understand it he only he only
works inside his little white box and
that's why it's all white supremacy here
and it's to make people like Madison go
out there and feel good about themselves
because you can't blame Madison gothorne
for you know
stealing the the Indians as he puts it
land that's that's the that's the
fallacy here is that we I'm a white
person
Gabe I do not walk around with any guilt
that my answer because some of my
ancestors came here
in in in the 17th century
we tracked back on my on my mom's side
in the tree they came here
from England and they came here in the
17th century so they were part of the
the stealing of the land I don't hold
any guilt even though I know that's the
truth
truth does not have to mean guilt right
and I I I well
and your heritage
has two sides right yeah mine mine has
really well I'm I'm really a really
pasty white dude like through and
through I'm a pasty white dude yeah but
your heritage has two different stories
right yeah and I mean even even the
story of like from my father's side you
know I've got Spanish background and
Mexicans but you know and and
indigenous uh of Mexico right and I've
got one group coming from Spain and
decimating raping pillaging the other
half or the other half of my half of my
my background right so it's like it's
very complicated I mean like and then
you know my grandparents my mom's side
came over much later
but even if you look at Just My Father's
Side I've like even within the Latino
Community I've already got one one group
just like you know Christopher Columbus
and all you know all these other people
that are coming over in a non-fucking
genocide way uh even though they are I
mean destroy like even if you look at
Mexico City right like Mexico City was
completely advanced in the engineering
that was there and in the waterways and
the marsh
demolished demolished and that's why you
see Mexico City actually sinking because
it's built on like a Marshland right but
for even for me for one half of my side
which is like I've got family in Mexico
the other half came from Spain and
and just you know like that side is all
right because even because even you're
dancing enough even your dad's culture
is built is built on the Spanish Crown
taking over the indigenous people
of Mexico right like that that entire
culture is built on that just like our
culture that we have here in this
country is built upon the foundation of
us stealing indigenous people's land and
enslaving black people African people to
come here and build our country and our
in our [ __ ] economy in our society
like literally this is what it's built
on now do we have to hold guilt because
we're white no no you don't have to hold
guilt you can have truth and not have
guilt now if you feel guilty about it if
you feel guilty about it my belief is
this is just my belief it's not an
opinion it's a belief because I I can't
prove this beyond the shadow of a doubt
this is true but my belief is if that
you are a person who holds guilt for
what happened
that that is beyond your control but the
truth makes you feel guilt
it is either one of two ways you are
either a [ __ ] bigot are you truly
have not come to know who you really are
that is my belief that Matt walsher
either truly doesn't know who he is or
he's a bigot and I'll prove it to you in
just the [ __ ] statements that he
gives let's listen only the law of
Conquest which is a law that all people
lived by and died by there are winners
and losers in such a system here's this
is
Nuance well here it is
in a world governed by the law of
Conquest which is how the whole world
was governed for thousands of years
there are winners and losers
but it is much harder to identify
villains and victims
you know by the law of the land at the
time it's hard to make villains out of
Indian tribes that for example massacred
settlements you piece of [ __ ] that's
just how it worked and they were on the
settlements were on land that those
Indian tribes wanted or felt that they
had a right to
modern people love to Feast at the
banquet of Western Civilization while
still whining about the people who
provided the banquet there it is right
there we are better than you us white
people provided what you add today you
should be grateful and you should be
thanking us because white people are the
reason why this and the reason why that
this is the white supremacy this is the
[ __ ] this is this is where he is a
bigot and he is totally insecure about
the truth because it makes him feel
guilty right
and it doesn't make him feel Superior
and here's the thing you don't like just
accepting the truth doesn't mean you
inherently feel guilt
did we lose him
what I think you're froze oh oh there
you are now you're good now you're good
so what what I'm saying is like the idea
of Matt Walsh being like Oh you you know
feel guilty and all this [ __ ] you
don't have to feel guilty okay you
accept the truth and you learn from that
and say how do we do better
as a society how do we improve ourselves
how do we progress forward and take what
we did in the past and say that was
really [ __ ] up we should not do that
right we understand that when regions
get uh you know whether it's advancement
military uh equipment or strategy or
people or whatever it is they're going
to naturally have this desire as we've
seen over time Wars waged over religion
and political ideologies and all these
things
and yes you look at America and what we
were like what it was established on and
it's a very gross background it is a
very violent past and accepting it
doesn't mean
that we have to say oh you know what
everyone should feel guilty yeah you
should look and be like that was [ __ ]
up that was something terrible we should
never have done that and also look at
and say like how do we never come back
to this again
by teaching and educating people to
understand what mistakes we've made in
the past to make sure that what we do in
the future is better you know I I can't
agree more now Amanda points out
something that someone keeps pointing
out oh yeah you keep pointing this out
do you see this in the background here's
[ __ ] here yeah and he's got his he's
got his book because he can't figure out
what a woman is right and he's got his
like basketball trophy is that what that
is yeah 2022 probably his indoor
basketball league he probably bought it
from a local local trophy shop who's
like yeah put put put MVP on there right
I should I should put a trophy behind me
but he's got this banjo here which
really is
it does but you do you see this thing
right here what though it's a baby it's
a baby Matt Walsh crawling because I I
too what is this why is that there I
don't know I'm sure okay hold on
I've had several people pointing out
like on screenshots and [ __ ] and
Amanda's saying she can't stop focusing
on this Matt Walsh now it looks like it
has a diaper on but again yeah it's a
it's a baby Matt Walsh a crawling baby
matte Walsh with a diaper on does he
sell this thing
uh
um I don't know you can buy a little
baby version of this poster on Redbubble
but I don't know I mean most most you
know really egotistical people if
they're gonna put something that is a
image of them behind them they would
they're like a bobble head right okay so
they'll do a bobblehead the background
is
it's called sweet baby gang oh so that's
what's on his coffee mug here watch this
sweet sweet baby gang that's what it is
so if you look at his coffee mug right
here that's what it says on the coffee
mug it's sweet baby gang so that is that
is what that is
the guy who constantly talks about
children and children's genitalia and
what bathrooms are going into are you
telling me his catchphrase and his merch
says sweet baby gang yeah yep that is
correct what the [ __ ] listen I had a lot
of a lot of things to say about Matt
Walsh and I did not know this this is
just something that I'm finding out I
don't know if you guys are just finding
this sound but this [ __ ]
do you have do you have like a link to
his merch store or something so we can
show this sweet baby gang are you
[ __ ] kidding me
okay I found something as a four minute
clip that explains the
the uh he explains it no somebody else
made a video yeah a month ago okay let's
let's see supposedly this is the origin
of the sweet baby gang
okay so this is this is where it came
from is what you're saying
yeah okay let's see if we can this is
not his video this is a video that
somebody else made I hate to uh snuff
this out but this is important stuff
here it's this video is called the
origins of Sweet Baby gang now let's see
if we can
so the actress Monique recently got
herself in the hot water because of
comments she made about the way
according to her
some black women dress and present
themselves in public she was inspired to
offer this criticism after noticing lots
of slovenly attire at the airport she
spoke about the issue for several
minutes and then did a follow-up video
further explaining it but uh here's some
of the original Instagram posts let's
watch
and as we begin to walk through the
airport
I saw
so many actually too many to count and
too many for me to tap
but I saw so many of our young sisters
in head bonnets
scarves
slippers
pajamas
blankets wrapped around them and this is
how they're showing up to the airport
and it
I've been seeing it not just at the
airport I've been standing at a store at
the mall I've been seeing sisters
showing up with these do you remember
this video I don't remember this video
[Music]
what is she talking about she's offended
the people are showing up in pajamas at
the airport it sounds like that yeah I
mean I mean if I well I think so but the
reason why I would imagine people show
up at the airport in pajamas because
they're gonna sleep on the plane right
I mean I'm just I'm just trying to use
like
rash and rational thought here like okay
I know where you can skip this uh but go
to go to one
go to like 115 116. one okay okay all
right I didn't think this is I didn't
think that it was a point he was making
I think for this one okay
now after watching that I'm beginning to
think I need to start softening some of
my more controversial takes by calling
the audience sweet babies
seems to work for Monique something
tells me it wouldn't work as well for me
all right let's go now to
um reading the YouTube comments
says uh there was something so unnatural
about hearing Matt utter the words my
sweet babies
Anthony says Matt calling all of us
sweet babies gave me PTSD
but another comment says okay so Matt's
fan base is officially known as the
sweet baby gang there you go I
I guess I can't really tell anyone else
how to identify themselves if you want
to be the sweet baby gang you can be
okay so now now he's not able to show in
that video that woman I believes used
the phrase sweet baby oh and then he
looks he called it sweet he's like I
gotta soften it for these sweet babies
and then in the follow-up they're like
oh we're now the sweet baby gang or the
saying
the fan group or the supporters or the
Watchers or whatever are sweet baby gang
and that is where he got it from
I love it we're the [ __ ] them fan yeah
and he's got the sweet baby gang which I
I see what he's saying now so she was
calling these weak frail people who are
showing up in pajamas I guess maybe in
the airport babies sweet babies
um so he said the word and then they
took off with it let's finish to see if
he how he embraced it here
yeah you know what let's go with that
just just to really confuse everybody
who doesn't listen to the show
hundreds of submissions
five finalists
three judges
One winner
this is the daily wire search for the
official sweet baby gang Anthem okay I I
can't do that anymore that's [ __ ]
creeping me out
what the [ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] wow all
of those guys are idiots and that is how
it came yeah he took a phrase that a
black woman used and then the community
was like we should use it as a sweet
baby gang and that's what we should be
called and then I guess they voted on it
because that matters
and it sounds like it so yeah it looks
like it looks like here it says Monique
always addresses her subscribers that
way
so again he took something
that she uses right because I don't I
don't uh follow or listen to Monique so
this is news to me but I from what it
sounds like it sounds like she said she
calls her subscribers oh baby she calls
them sweet babies right so he wait a
second you're telling me Matt Walsh
appropriated the [ __ ] that's what I
said he stole this fridge I mean it only
makes more sense that this guy would be
the person that would do it see I
thought it had to do with this sick
obsession with children because sweet
babies but well probably I I would
imagine maybe it's a double once he
heard it Matt Walsh was like oh yeah
babies I love babies babies and then
yeah saw that as a potential [ __ ]
yeah weirdo speaking of weirdos did you
see the Mike Lindell news apparently
he's been sanctioned by a Michigan judge
for issuing frivolous subpoena as an
official Expedition somebody also I
think we have uh hold on let me just
make sure do we have some more breaking
news
um let me just confirm
we have something from what doj looks
like it was 27 minutes ago so what
happened it's the rail strike so it
looks like the house has voted to pass a
bill to avert the rail strike by a
margin of two to one uh looks like 79
Republicans joined Democrats to pass it
so well yeah because they don't they
can't it's that one thing Republicans
can't have is as soon as they take
Congress the [ __ ] the the railways
grind to a screeching halt
um as they take anger so that was likely
to pass a lot of people were upset about
that because they got um as opposed to
seven or nine days off I believe is what
the union was looking for yeah um the
agreement was one day off a year I think
is uh people are upset about which I
mean that is something to be upset about
but we definitely don't need the
railways to grind to a a screeching halt
here so I'm I'm happy that Congress and
the administration was able to reach a
deal to keep uh the rails open I mean
because we are we are down to
you know because what what when do they
go for recess
um I think they only I think they only
have like 13 uh actual session days left
and then they come back when they're
when like no that's from now to the end
of the year I think they have 13 or 14
sessions
and then January third is whenever right
or whatever correct yeah well because
they'll have their Christmas break
um and then they have their weekends so
it's there's only so many days for
session here
um which I think that's the the
um the thing about the Nancy Pelosi
tweet this morning about the respect for
Marriage Act it seems like she's going
to try to draw that to the floor as fast
as she can
um because they definitely want to make
sure that gets voted on before the Nazis
take over the House of Representatives
because we know that they're not gonna
they're not gonna bring that bill and
vote for it now Hakeem Jeffries is is
trending why is there something because
he was voted okay so so that is news
yeah yeah um that happened before that
happened before the show started okay I
yeah I was I was trying to figure out um
some news on the Oath Keepers yeah um so
I wasn't paying attention but Hakeem
Jeffries apparently uh has been voted in
unanimously I hear Philip Lewis has it
let me let me show this here now if
you're not following Philip you should
um rather on Twitter or other platforms
but he says Washington AP Akeem Jeffries
unanimously
I like the leader of the House Democrats
will be the first black person to lead
major party in Congress which that's a
great feat um not not only uh is that
history but it's history that Hakeem
Jeffries is because this guy is and we
know we talked about this you know after
after the election we were saying like
who could be you know the next leader of
the of the House of the democratic house
and you know we talked about Hakeem and
you know all of these clips I'm sure
this is one of them you're gonna pull up
but this is the one about Jeannie Thomas
here yeah and every single one that he
had this is a great one but every single
one that he has is always [ __ ] fire
right no [ __ ] no [ __ ] given right
the guy's like look I'm in a position of
power and I'm gonna call this [ __ ] out
and I'm gonna call it how I see it
and this is why you elected me in office
because he's great at narrative too
which I think is going to be a huge
change he's great at narrative he's
great at messages let's listen to the
front of this clip and if Justice Thomas
really wants to deal with bullying in
America or this problem of people
supposedly unwilling to accept
outcomes that they don't like I've got
some advice for justice Thomas starting
your own home
have a conversation with Jeannie Thomas
she refused to accept the legitimacy of
the 2020 presidential election why
because she didn't like the outcome and
there's there's the new leader of the
House leaders the Democrats uh in the
house which if if we do our jobs for
democracy and we get out and make sure
that we engage in our democracy in 2024
it's possible that Akeem Jeffries could
be the next uh Democratic uh speaker of
the house I mean it's a it's about time
and I'm also glad to see him in that
position to have that absolutely
leadership over the party well you know
this also this also undermines a lot of
the [ __ ] that we get from the right
where it's like Nancy Pelosi this and
Nancy Pelosi that Nancy Pelosi this
um this is going to undermine a lot of
that narrative because she's no longer
in that leadership role um now of course
you know I'm sure she's going to be
consult thing because
I'm not always a Nancy Pelosi fan I'll
say that outright
um and and more style than anything but
there is no person on this planet Gabe
that knows the House of Representatives
and procedures better oh Nancy Pelosi I
mean I can only imagine the Rolodex that
Nancy Pelosi has on people to be like oh
this person you know their interests are
this and they do this and I mean like
she knows everyone strikes strengths and
weaknesses to say like all right we
should definitely approach it this way
you should be more combative or you
should be more like you should be less
combative or you should bring this up or
you should talk about this or you should
you know invite them to do this like you
want to get them you know if you're
trying to whip votes up you know you got
to figure out how to read people and I
think you know Nancy Pelosi is does such
a great job at that I mean she's an
effective leader within the Democratic
party especially as Speaker of the House
she is someone who
uh has done a good job and now this
you've got a younger person a person of
color coming into position a person who
doesn't [ __ ] you know again
give zero [ __ ] on what you think more
or less because he's like look
I don't know how long I'm gonna have
this position so I might as well call
this [ __ ] out now because nothing is
guaranteed and to have someone like that
and to have someone who is who is
filling that position I think is a huge
a huge milestone but also to still have
Nancy Pelosi in her position as like an
advisor or someone that could say this
is how you know as like the transition
process into into bringing them into
that position
um I think is definitely welcomed and
also something of value that still have
her around you know right well and I
think Nancy Pelosi um will hold her seat
as long as she wants to
um regardless of leadership or not
leadership she'll hold that seat
um it is a secure seat that's the other
thing that's most important about uh
leadership in in the House of
Representatives of the Senate that
people need to understand is that the
reason why a lot of times you see
certain people who are you would like oh
there they would be a great leader but
they can't be is because they don't hold
as secure of a seat right your
leadership has to hold those secure
seats it has to be something that they
can continue to be in leadership for a
long time you can't risk like um you
remember Eric Cantor you remember that
guy yeah yeah he got primaried he got
primaried and he got he was leadership
and it was a huge blow to Republican
party and the reason why is because they
had a leader who wasn't a leader because
a leader does not lose their seat that
is just not a thing a leader does and
that's why Donald Trump is not a leader
that's why he's a loser right because he
lost he lost the popular vote several
times now and he's probably going to
lose it several more
um and also and also unanimous too I
mean let's let's talk about that that
right I think a huge huge vote of
confidence from the Democratic party to
be like
we unanimously voted to have this person
as our leader well I think the other
signal that they could send and maybe
maybe I'm just off my rocker here but it
also could send a a clear message to the
Republicans you better get your [ __ ]
together and you better pick a speaker
because we we will unanimously vote for
someone yeah yeah right like we're not
in fighting like they could the
Republican Party can almost already
guarantee that if it comes up against
Kevin McCarthy or or whoever they
actually vote for margin Taylor green or
whatever the [ __ ] it is versus Akeem
you already know that you've got the
Democratic party like yeah [ __ ] yeah we
already voted for this got to be
Democratic Leadership we're going to
vote for him to be the speaker of the
house right so you now have to fight
against 100 of that group to go against
like how many was the difference there's
like two
what do you know what the difference is
from right now um I'm not really sure
because there was a democratic
Congressman that that passed away in
Virginia right
um that's probably going to be that
seat's gonna be filled temporarily by
junkan
um now if Junkin does the right thing
and actually you know uh gives a
Democrat that see but I doubt he will
he'll probably give it to Republican
until there's a special election and I
believe I'm not exactly sure
um how their special elections work in
Virginia but I'm sure sometime next year
they'll elect another Congress person in
the district
um so like right now it's 213 to 220
right is the current map that's there
and you need 218 for control so
Democrats only need five Republicans
right to vote in their favor right and
and and Democrats Democrats they have
signaled that they are easily
um giving a unanimous vote so they can
unanimously vote for someone that the
Republicans don't necessarily want even
if it's a republican right that may be
the signal all also that they're sending
there and I'm sure it was arranged by
the master vote counter uh Nancy Pelosi
um so everyone running out of time but I
um and we didn't get to talk much Gabe
me and you about Stuart Rhodes um being
yeah found guilty of sedition but I I
I've already messaged
um Tasha and Dakota to see if they want
to come on the show
so if we arrange an interview with them
of course we'll play it here on the show
uh maybe we can get them on live or
something get the reaction there's
actually uh Dakota was on Twitter spaces
last night
yeah and The Daily Beast has done a
couple articles so if you want to go out
uh show Dakota and Tasha some support
um they're relieved that Stewart now is
going to be facing sentencing in a
federal prison
um because of not just because of
January 6 but he's a monster not just
because he's a seditious monster but
he's also a monster to them personally
so yeah so show them some support if you
can today go give them some
encouragement I'm sure they're getting a
lot of hate out there but um so go find
Tasha and Dakota on Twitter and give him
some love today
um they're probably going to need uh
plenty of it but I I have a feeling
they're relieved yeah and again I've
reached out to them and I talked to him
last night but not too much I'm hoping
that we'll uh we'll get their thoughts
and feelings if they want to come if
they want to come talk
um to to the audience and tell how they
feel about Stuart Rose being found
guilty of sedition so everybody same
time same place tomorrow remember bone
end of the week is back this week baby
we are back and we are better than ever
so go to Twitter at Tony Michael's spot
as long as Twitter's on the App Store
now follow us there you can vote there
you can also vote on the YouTube well
vote on the YouTube channel and what
happened you can vote on the YouTube
channel in the community tab so um so
make sure to subscribe to the YouTube
channel and then download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google make
sure to leave us a great review while
you're subscribing there and if you're
on the Midas touch Facebook page don't
forget to come follow us at the Tony
Michaels page I know I've been a little
lazy because of Thanksgiving putting up
memes but as I find them I will try to
post stuff that I find if I think it's
[ __ ] hilarious you know I'll post it
there so go follow us on Twitter and
I'll download the Twitch app while
you're at it why not why why the hell on
why the hell not and go to
store.thetonymichaels.com we still have
the dark Brandon merch over there
they're still over there if you want to
get your family dark Brandon or dank
Brandon merch go to store at the Johnny
michaels.com they make great Christmas
gifts days and they support the show and
we we appreciate all your support you're
the best audience in the world until
tomorrow same time same place noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch simulcasting on
Facebook Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
laughs
foreign